britney spears elicited concern among  her fans after posting a series of full  front naked pictures on instagram so  this is something that britney spears is  doing apparently a lot she just posts  these  these naked pictures all the time she's  a 40 year old woman by the way and but  the story here is that now her fans are  concerned which  gives me an opportunity you know how  hesitant i am to do it and you know how  much i hate to do this  but it does give me an opportunity that  i have to take advantage of to say  i mean i told you so what if britney  spears is actually insane though  but all the um all the fans got together  said free brittany take her out of the  out of the conservatorship  and now the people that were in that  movement are saying i don't know she  seems to be kind of crazy well yeah  that's that's generally that that's how  you end up you lose customer your kids  you end up with a good supportership  it's because you're crazy  so nicely done  everybody